-The purpose of the watch is
to determine exactly how
Anna O'Donnell has survived with
no food.
-So you want us to watch her?
-Yes.
On the 14th day, you will each
present your separate testimony.
-How long exactly has it been
since the last time
the girl ate?
-Four months.
-That's impossible.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Florence Pugh,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from "The Wonder."
Now, this is a period piece, and
I think sometimes when you hear
that an actor is
doing a period piece,
they might be drawn to
the costumes
and the beautiful grandeur
of it.
This is one of the muddiest
period pieces ever.
-Not glamorous at all.
-No, it's not very glamorous.
Did you enjoy sort of stomping
through the mud?
-Yes, completely opposite to Amy
in "Little Women."
-It really is, yeah.
-I had one outfit.
[ Laughter ]
-It was kind of
a one-outfit movie.
-It is.
-There's a great many animals
on set.
Did you have any high jinks?
-We shot --
-I should note, this is not
a high-jinks movie.
-No.
-It's very serious.
And thankfully we didn't all
become really serious people.
But we were shooting on the top
of mountains for months
and weeks, and it was so windy,
and you'd see all four seasons
in one day.
And whenever you'd work with
the animals on the mountains,
they were also like,
"Why are we on a mountain?"
[ Laughter ]
"It's really windy and cold."
And there was one take we were
walking with a horse,
and the horse just turned around
sideways and was like, "Nope."
[ Laughter ]
"Not walking anymore."
And I had a sheep run into me,
and I face-planted in mud.
Like, full-on mud, and the whole
set had, you know,
when we were working outside,
we'd shooting in these
tiny little villages that people
would be coming and visiting,
and, like, fans would would be
coming and waiting, just,
"It's exciting,
there's a film set."
And on this one day there was
probably 50 to 60 people waiting
on the side of the barriers,
just like with their iPhones
like this.
And I had a very simple scene
where I had to walk across.
Just walk across the road
like that. Just walk.
But with really intense facial
expressions going on.
And as I was walking past
this sheep,
the sheep wouldn't move
out of the way.
So I, like, gently patted
the bum.
And that sheep went like, "Rrr!"
And then another sheep next to
it went, like, "Rrr!"
[ Laughter ]
And then that sheep ran into me.
And I flipped over the sheep and
went straight down into cowpat.
It was like full-on mud.
It was great.
-And this is when all your fans
were there.
-Yeah, yeah,
filming the whole thing.
There was a photographer there.
Instantly the next day,
it was on "Daily Mail,
like, "sheep got better of Flo."
[ Laughter ]
Thanks for that.
-Obviously, you're
an accomplished actor.
I'm sure this doesn't
bother you.
But is it strange when you're
doing a period piece like that
and you can also see, like,
everybody with --
-Yeah.
-Fans with modern iPhones
and stuff?
-Yeah, it's also that --
It's cool.
They're there all day, and so
you kind of have to also be
very aware that it accidentally
is a tough day for them as well
because they've been there
since 6:00 a.m.
But no, it's --
I love doing those films.
I love getting in the costume.
I don't like having wet feet,
though.
-Yeah. No, there's nothing worth
having wet feet for.
I don't even like going to the
beach because your feet get wet.
-All the shoes are essentially
like a leather sock.
When you walk around in mud,
your foot is trench foot.
-It's not great.
-No.
-This is, like we were talking
about, a very serious film.
There's superstition.
There's religion.
I would imagine a fairly heavy
head space to be in
when you're doing a movie
like that.
You did say
you didn't get serious.
But what do you do when you're
on a set like that
to also let yourself have
relaxing thoughts?
-Right, well, so that -- there
was a secret to that, which was
when we'd be on a mountain and
it was really, really cold
and really windy and everybody
was like,
"How are we still here,
oh, my God,"
me and my mate, my assistant,
came up to me and Jesse would
look at me like this,
and I would respond,
"It's a 'Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills' kind of night."
And so, like, I'd be in this
mountain with all of
these things, and we would
basically be plotting
when we were going to get home
and watch "Real Housewives."
[ Laughter ]
And then we'd get home and have
our G&T with our little crackers
and be like...
"What are you going to say?"
-I will say, watching the film,
if you said guess what TV show
I was watching while I made it,
that would have been
my last guess.
-I was channeling
"Beverly Hills."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, thank you for being here.
Have a wonderful Thanksgiving.
-Thank you.
-And as always,
a delight to see you.
You guys, that's Florence Pugh.
"The Wonder" is in select
theaters now
and available on Netflix
November 16th.
We'll be right back
with Steve Kornacki.